[Música]
Hola Esto es África 7 días el magazine
donde les presentamos la actualidad del
continente africano Mi nombre es amal
benoffmann Y estos son los titulares
dedicamos parte de esta edición a Chad
donde 60 personas murieron y al menos
300 resultaron heridas como consecuencia
de violentos enfrentamientos tras
manifestaciones contra el mantenimiento
del General mahama Debi en el poder
Enrique pico directora del International
crisis Group para África Central es
nuestra invitada y seguimos en gana
donde la inflación es tal que los
comerciantes de la capital acra
decidieron cerrar sus tiendas durante
varios días en protesta por la situación
económica del país veremos también que
gana no es el único país que atraviesa
estas dificultades y terminamos nuestro
recorrido por África en Egipto vamos al
ejemplo de su grave Lula en El delta del
Nilo de donde procede la mayor parte del
Jazmín que se vende en el mundo
manifestaciones contra el poder han
sacudido Chad especialmente la capital
llamena la fuerza pública reprimió las
concentraciones con una violencia sin
precedentes el número de víctimas se
eleva a 60 muertos al menos y más de 300
heridos tras el anuncio de que el
general mahama debby seguiría en el
poder y que la transición se prolongaría
a otros 24 meses una coalición de
organizaciones civiles y partidos
políticos convocaron las manifestaciones
para exigir la aceleración de la
transición veamos
acabar con un poder que califican de
dinástico con esta consigna la oposición
chadiana justificó su convocatoria a
protestar una coalición de
organizaciones y partidos políticos
llamó a manifestaciones pacíficas para
exigir La retirada de los militares la
junta que está al frente del país desde
el asesinato del ex presidente idris
devi en abril de 2021 había prometido
entregar el poder al cabo de 18 meses de
transición pero esta promesa fue rota
con el anuncio de que mahama debby
seguiría en el poder durante dos años
más
las manifestaciones convocadas por la
oposición tras esta proclamación fueron
violentamente reprimidas
el opositor saké más radenunció que el
ejército disparó contra las ambulancias
hasta en los patios de los hospitales
20 de octubre de 2022 disparan a las
ambulancias en los hospitales el
gobierno culpó a los chadianos que
salieron a la calle y los calificó de
Insurgentes que Habían intentado un
golpe de estado
estos Insurgentes tienen la gran
responsabilidad de unos 50 muertos y
casi 300 heridos especialmente en yamena
julianos
de la República del chat velará para que
el orden reine en todo el país y que no
tolerará ningún exceso venga de donde
venga rápido
Francia aliada diplomática del gobierno
chadiano consideró necesario dejar Claro
que no tenía ningún papel en los
acontecimientos que eran estrictamente
una cuestión de política interna de chat
la unión africana que hasta ahora no ha
sancionado al país a diferencia de otros
regímenes instalados al margen de las
normas constitucionales en Mali y Guinea
conakry ha condenado la represión de las
manifestaciones
para analizar la situación en chat nos
acompaña en Erika pico directora del
International crisis Group para África
Central endrica pico Gracias por estar
con nosotros como Lo acabamos de ver en
el informe las autoridades militares
reprimieron fuertemente las
manifestaciones estamos hablando de 60
muertos y más de 300 heridos Porque esa
reacción de las autoridades
no es la primera vez que el régimen de
la transición reacciona de manera
violenta las manifestaciones Aunque haya
sido una transición en los últimos 18
meses pacífica mayoritariamente pacífica
ya hubo represiones de la manifestación
de la sociedad civil y de la oposición
política en mayo y sobre todo en
septiembre con más de 200 miembros de la
partido de oposición de transformación
arrestados y destros liberados después
de unos días
dicho esto las tensiones estaban
a la capital porque
la conclusión del diálogo nacional
entonces la extensión de la transmisión
pero sobre todo el hecho que los jefes
militares se puedan candidar a las
elecciones al final de la transición en
dos años
suscitó la reacciones de la mayoría de
los ciudadanos de la capital y de muchas
ciudades en el sur
la reacción fue tan violenta porque los
militares que están en el poder
ya tienen Claro que no no van a querer
dejar este poder al final de la
transición Aunque repitan su compromiso
por las elecciones al final de la
transición es muy claro que la élite al
poder que sigue en el mismo sitio desde
hace más de 30 años
no quiere dejar espacio a fuerza
política y a nuevas generaciones por
esto Esta primera reacción fue tan dura
y se pueden y la represión está
continuando estos días en el país
la unión africana nunca ha sancionado a
cada diferencia de otros países
porque la junta chayanna que gobierna
inconstitucionalmente se beneficia de un
trato diferente
Sí de hecho la unión africana no
sancionada en abril 2021 pero puso dos
condiciones muy claras para evitar estas
sanciones la primera condición era que
la transición no durará más de 18 meses
renovables una sola vez y esta condición
ya la hemos bueno ya en el régimen la
está saltando la segunda condición aún
más importante para la mayoría de los
chayanos era que los miembros de la
transición de la junta militar y del
gobierno de transición no pudieran
presentarse a las elecciones que tenían
que marcarla la vuelta a la democracia
la unión africana como muchos países
occidentales condando la violencia del
jueves pasado porque fue la violencia en
brutal y una reacción a una reacción
desproporcionada a unas manifestaciones
que empezaron como que le generaron
también en unos actos de violencia y que
pero no para hacer contenida No no
necesitaban uno de violencia tan brutal
directamente contra los manifestantes
con agua de fuego
pero no condar la junta no no cuando no
puramente la junta por no haber
respetado estas condiciones entonces aún
esperamos un posicionamiento claro de la
unión africana y desde otros países
occidentales sobre todo la Unión Europea
en la Francia que estuvieron apoyando la
transición esta fase de la transición
hasta ahora para que
digan claramente como si posicionan
de Cara a la próxima parte de la
transición
la oposición y las organizaciones de la
sociedad civil exige en el regreso de
los civiles al poder completar la
transición democrática ayudaría al país
a salir de la crisis estamos hablando de
una crisis que no solo es política sino
también económica y social
una una abertura democrática y
elecciones transparentes libera después
de 30 años de regímena sin duda
permitirán de calmar los ánimos de la
población los ánimos de los opositores
políticos y militares
sin embargo esto no será suficiente para
celebrar el país de una crisis que como
decía nuestro política pero también
social y económica Hay muchísimas
inaguaridades hay muchísima también hubo
muchísimos también abusos de poder y
corrupción por parte de la élite que
gobernó el país de esa en los últimas
décadas todo esto no se cambia de un día
a otro necesita una se necesita antes de
todo un cambio en el liderazgo del país
que pueda permitir el acceso al poder
también de miembros y otros grupos de
población
que la élite que está gobernando el país
a Los chacaguas
representan una minoría en entonces hay
muchos otros grupos y muchos otro parte
de la población que pide el acceso al
poder después de tantos años y después
de esto claramente hace falta reformas
sobre todo de la gobernancia sobre todo
de la transparente de las instituciones
democráticas y también una abertura
económica que permita a la población
joven que es la más que también está
formando la parte más importante de las
protestas de solegarse de Buscar
oportunidades para el futuro y
de permitir al país de hacer un cambio
endrica pico Gracias por estar con
nosotros Hablamos ahora de economía en
ghana los precios subieron un 37% en
septiembre después de que la moneda
local el Cedis se desplomara frente al
dólar estadounidense lo que llevó a los
comerciantes de la capital acra a cerrar
sus tiendas durante varios días en
protesta por la inflación
para hacer frente a la crisis el
presidente ganes Nana acupó a dos se ha
visto obligado a entablar conversaciones
con el fondo monetario internacional a
pesar de que había prometido que el país
nunca necesitaría recurrir a ninguna
forma de préstamo entre la población
esta decisión ha suscitado el temor de
que el gobierno imponga medidas de
austeridad pero no Solo ganas será
afectado por la inflación provocada
entre otros factores por la guerra entre
Rusia y Ucrania en este mapa pueden ver
los países africanos más afectados por
la subida de los precios los dos países
más impactados son zimbabwe y Sudán con
tasas de inflación del
284,9% y
154,9% respectivamente seguidos de
Etiopía Angola y gana
cambiamos de tema y de su región cuando
se trata de perfumes uno piensa
inmediatamente en las grandes marcas de
fragancias internacionales sin embargo
pocos saben que uno de los ingredientes
claves de muchas de estas marcas procede
de un pueblo de Egipto llamado su
travelula situado a unos 97 kilómetros
al norte de la capital El Cairo este
pequeño pueblo del delta del Nilo
cultiva más de la mitad de la producción
mundial del Jazmín allá los llevamos
la mayoría de la gente reconocería su
aroma floral pero pocos saben que gran
parte de la producción mundial de Jazmín
procede de aquí el pueblo de xura vilula
en El delta del Nilo al norte del Cairo
el cultivo de esta flor es el sustento
de la mayoría de los aproximadamente
15.000 habitantes de la localidad
imágenes
llevamos 15 años recogiendo Jazmín aquí
se considera la temporada de Jazmín para
todo el pueblo la temporada de
recolección de Jazmín dura unos seis
meses empezamos a recoger las flores
desde las tres o cuatro de la mañana
hasta las 7 u 8 luego llevamos las
flores de Jazmín al proveedor que las
entrega la fábrica Esta es la mejor
época del año para recoger las flores ya
que están húmedas porque están cubiertas
del rocío y completamente abiertas
en el campo de las aromáticas cubrimos
una variedad muy amplia de productos
pero uno de los más emblemáticos es el
Jazmín junto con India Egipto es
básicamente el principal productor y en
los últimos cinco o seis años Hemos
llegado a producir mucho más de lo que
en indias
pero los últimos años han sido difíciles
para los agricultores primero se vieron
afectados por la pandemia y ahora por la
guerra de Rusia en Ucrania el cambio
climático supone otro reto la
disminución de la producción aún así
Egipto queda entre los principales
productores del mundo exporta un
concentrado conocido bajo el nombre
absoluto que se envía a Europa y otros
lugares donde se fabrican la mayoría de
los perfumes de las grandes marcas
así termina la edición de esta semana
gracias por su sintonía nos vemos la
próxima semana
[Música]